community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
welcome back southwest medical and
associates the sponsors of this next
segment are back to continue their 50th
anniversary celebration this time
they're helping build the friendship
circle of las vegas check it out
i'm so excited to help spread this word
it's so important i'm dr rosenberg we're
celebrating 50 years of southwest
medical we're continuing the celebration
of the anniversary so let's just start
off with you and what you do for
southwest medical
okay thank you so much for having all of
us today so at southwest medical i'm the
medical director of hospice and
palliative care
in doing this we provide care to the
most medically fragile and at risk
patients that optum serves
we provide care
uh almost almost exclusively in patients
homes so 98 plus we go to people's homes
um that is where they find the most
comfort so that's where we follow them
we do uh follow our palliative care
patients to other settings such as
hospitals and skilled nursing facilities
when they need that level of care but we
really
know that people prefer to be at home
so as as the medical director i visit
individuals in their homes and we also
support caregivers and have
caregiver support groups for our
palliative care and hospice families
which we're really uh proud about you
mentioned support groups and i think
this is the perfect segue to another
type of support group so let's talk to
you nahamah you are the director of the
friendship circle las vegas what do you
guys do for the community
all right well thanks for having us here
and i guess quite simply the friendship
circle is a non-profit that aims to
create a more inclusive community for
individuals with disabilities um we
believe that everyone
um deserves to have a friend and
everyone can be a friend so pulling that
all together
is you know have a powerful
can have such a powerful impact for
anyone who chooses to get involved
absolutely and and rabbi how does
friendship circle actually carry out
that mission so friendship circle
carries out our mission through various
programs activities and events we just
put our calendar for the year again the
mission is to
get
teens young adults together in a
array of programs and activities to have
fun time while making friends and we've
got events for the friendship circle
specifically we also have some events
that are open to the community as a as a
whole one of them coming up on august
22nd
it's an event
to discuss and stop break the stigma or
surrounding mental health suicide
prevention and we are encouraging the
community at large to join so everyone
can learn the teenagers teens parents
professionals to learn
how to be a better friend and help
support
of the community who may be struggling
absolutely and unfortunately there's
been such an uptick in that so this is
such an important event um
how can people help you guys
around the community
i think specifically right now as i said
uh my attire is not so weather
appropriate we wanted to show off some
of our um
awesome things that you'll see at the at
the mental health awareness event you'll
get a chance to pick up one of these um
but that's a good merch right there
there you go that's really it you know
come help us spread the word bring your
family and friends
free and open to the public so it's just
a great opportunity to get involved in
an impactful way hope to see you there
thank you to southwest medical
associates for being one of our
community pride partners all right some
severe weather